[Musica]
ovviamente nicolas con cui ci conosciamo
da 15 anni è andato accettare un
musicista che sa che io odio per
infastidirmi prima dello speech
ma non importa siccome fortunatamente
c'era anche una presentatrice che
capisce di musica ha detto già due cose
interessanti su quest album della banana
di cui parleremo oggi è il primo che è
stato influente per il punk ma non solo
per il punk e chi di voi ha mai
ascoltato musica punk o musica new wave
o musica post rock
nessuno pensa te le manine aequo ce ne
sono tantissimi ecco voi dovete sapere
che quella cosa lì senza questo non
sarebbe esistita o comunque non sarebbe
esistita nel modo in cui noi oggi la
conosciamo oggi voi siete abituati con
spotify e quindi ci sono le playlist
oggi l'algoritmo di suggerisce delle
canzoni che potrebbero piacervi sulla
base di quelle che avete ascoltato o se
non vi piacciono i primi 10 secondi di
un brano voi potete saltare andare da
traccia successiva e non riascoltarlo
mai più
ma c'era un tempo non molto lontano in
cui le persone compravano i dischi e li
ascoltavano per intero e in questo
periodo le belle gli artisti avevano
spesso una lunga era considerato la loro
milestone e che non di rado coincideva
con l'album d'esordio come nel caso di
questo velvet underground and nico del
1967 di cui parliamo oggi che è
considerato da molti
l'album più bello e importante
dell'intera storia del rock
la copertina voi da qui la riuscita a
vedere realizzata da andy warhol
raffigura questa banana quello che voi
da lì sicuramente non vedete è che qui
c'è una scritta in piccolo più slowly
ensi che invita a sbucciare lentamente
osservare e se noi diamo retta questa
scritta e apriamo troviamo un interno di
banana però di colore rosa e lascia i
più arguti di voi immaginare cosa possa
far riferimento
questa scelta cromatica come nasce
questa milestone questa maisto nasce da
diversi passaggi
il primo e più importante avviene nel
1959 quando il futuro leader dei velvet
underground lewis allen reed a 17 anni
suona la chitarra tutto volume in casa
è insubordinato manifesta tendenze
omosessuali e i tradizionalisti genitori
decidono di rivolgersi a uno psichiatra
il quale gli prescrive un intervento di
un trattamento di elettroshock a noi
oggi sembra una cosa pazzesca
chiaramente in quegli anni era un
trattamento accettato non una volta ma
tre volte la settimana per otto
settimane negli anni 50 un parere medico
non è qualcosa che possa essere messo in
discussione
così il giovane lui inizia a recarsi al
credem state psychiatric hospital di
long island indossa il camice bianco e
si mette in fila con gli altri e li vede
passare dopo il trattamento che
ripassano catatonici quando nessun
momento viene portato in una stanza
viene sdraiato su un lettino legato
neanche fosse un pazzo un condannato a
morte gli viene somministrato un
sedativo gli viene passato un unguento
sulle tempie e gli viene fissato un
tampone in bocca perché non ingoi la
gola lui se ne sta lì sdraiato fissa le
barre di luce sul soffitto
fintanto che non perde conoscenza e
l'elettricità attraverso il suo corpo e
attenzione che in quel periodo il
voltaggio è unico non si fa distinzione
tra un minuto adolescente o un
energumeno corpulento quando lou reed si
sveglia ha perso la memoria
fortunatamente non in maniera
irreversibile
non puoi leggere un libro perché quando
arrivi a pagina 17 devi tornare indietro
a pagina 1
se lo metti giù per un ora e lo riprendi
in seguito non ricordi più cosa avevi
letto e devi ricominciare un altro
passaggio importante e quando inizia
l'università e si reca alla syracuse
university
perché qui avrà modo di incontrare una
personalità importante quella che lui
definirà l'uomo il primo grande uomo che
io abbia mai incontrato
il poeta diamond bar di 20 di cui
diventa il pupillo è che prevede per lui
un futuro radioso come scrittore del
mare stato il mio maestro mi ha cambiato
la vita
studiavo con lui al bar e cominciavamo a
bere alle 8 del mattino grazie a lui
iniziai a scrivere e contemporaneamente
suonavo in qualche gruppo rock
non ci vuole un granché ad avere l'idea
di metterlo
due cose insieme poi c'è un altro
passaggio che è importante nella
creazione di questo milestone che è
l'inizio di un rapporto con la droga ha
come molte altre rockstar che porterà a
una storia di tossicodipendenza per
molti anni a venire ma farà sì che in
questi anni dell'università dovrebbe
scrivere a due delle canzoni più
importanti che finiranno nell album
della banana waiting for the man che è
una canzone che parla di un tossico
bianco spaesato in un quartiere di mary
che aspetta lo spacciatore per avere la
propria dose e eroina che una canzone
che descrive in modo distaccato e
asettico gli effetti di un'iniezione di
eroina certo chi conosce queste canzoni
sa che poi sono molto articolate
nell'album sono queste sono ancora delle
versioni embrionali alla prima waiting
for the man ancora mancano le
martellanti tastiere che poi andranno a
caratterizzare
[Musica]
il marchio distintivo della seconda
invece sarà una viola elettrica distorta
finita l'università lou reed conosce jon
kyl un gallese trapiantato a new york
che alle spalle degli studi di
conservatorio in pianoforte e viola e
che ora suona anche il basso e si
esibisce con l'avanguardista newyorkese
la monte young eroina e quasi uno
schiaffo
nel periodo in cui la scrissi mi sentivo
davvero violento negativo
all'inizio sembra una canzone divertente
ma poi ti colpisce e continua a colpirti
sempre più forte sempre più in fretta
non hai più scampo
la monte vi insegna la disciplina
musicale insieme organizzano dei dream
syndacate che consisteva in due voci un
violino e la mia viola l'idea del gruppo
si basava su sostenere notte per una
durata di due ore alla volta
quella fu la mia prima esperienza in un
gruppo e che esperienza
ecco che quindi i due diventano subito
amici collaboratori e finiscono anche a
condividere un appartamento insieme a
new york per costituire una band devono
reclutare altri musicisti trovano il
chitarrista sterling morrison e il
batterista angus me please con lo stesso
mike leigh loro descrive anche un
manifesto che delinea gli intenti
programmatici del gruppo che ha un
titolo davvero eccentrico a proposito
della notizia per cui la cina comunista
avrebbe assunto il controllo del mercato
della metedrina esisterebbe affannando
ad aggiungerci gocce di paranoie per
sconvolgere l'equilibrio mentale degli
stati uniti
ecco al di là di questo titolo cosa dice
questo manifesto
quali sono questi intenti del gruppo
primo dedicarsi con fervore alla
vocazione collettiva
secondo essere diversi terzo essere
fedeli alla propria personalità quarto
rinunciare al successo immediato quinto
esibirsi per stesso per se stessi e non
per compiacere un pubblico e sesto non
suonare mai la stessa canzone due volte
nello stesso modo nel gruppo avevamo una
regola se qualcuno suonava un accordo
blues veniva multato i primi concerti
della band non sono dei veri e propri
ingaggi avvengono durante le proiezioni
dei film dei registi underground e
quando in effetti arriva il primo vero
ingaggio in un locale
si crea un problema col batterista mike
leigh di se volete dire che dovremo
salire sul palco a una data ora
cominciare a suonare e poi smettere
quando ce lo dicono noi rispondemmo si è
lui replicò beh io non ce la faccio
e la cosa finì lì e quindi il batterista
mcleans viene rimpiazzato dell'androgino
batterista maureen tucker e badate bene
che oggi noi siamo abituati alle figure
androgine ma quell epoca già avere una
batterista donna era una cosa che non
aveva nessuno e poi fosse una figura
androgina era veramente una cosa
sconvolgente ma con lei i velvet
underground ottengono la loro formazione
definitiva e iniziano a farsi le ossa in
giro fintanto che la svolta per loro
avviene quando ottengono un ingaggio di
due settimane in un club del greenwich
village il caffè bizarre perché in quel
posto
loro saranno notati niente poco di meno
che dall artista pop all'apice della sua
fama
andy warhol che in quel momento era il
catalizzatore di tutta la cultura
newyorkese
l'idea pop in fondo era che chiunque
potesse fare qualsiasi cosa
cercavamo ogni sviluppo creativo
possibile
ci mancava la musica ma poi incontrami
del mit underground quindi warhol che
sto cercando di entrare anche nella
musica per uno spettacolo multimediale
si propone di fare da manager il
produttore della band gli piacciono ma
non ha molte conoscenze in campo
musicale quindi non entra nel merito
delle scelte artistiche se non per due
aspetti il primo è che suggerisce alla
band di tenere le parolacce nel disco di
non ammorbidirlo con andranno a
registrarlo e il secondo è che propone
barra impone alla band la modella
tedesca nico come cantante di alcune
canzoni e questo è un suggerimento molto
intelligente perché la presenza scenica
la bellezza la voce al gilet di nico
creano un contrasto molto riuscito col
resto del gruppo
d'altro canto per lou reed non è un
rospo facile da ingoiare a voi dovete
pensare che è una persona e egocentrica
maniaca del controllo gelosa delle
proprie canzoni vedere che deve arrivare
questa bionda alta più di tutti loro e
cantare anche le canzoni che lui le deve
scrivere non è semplicissimo quindi si
trova questo compromesso per cui la band
diventerà the velvet underground and
nico in maniera da rimarcare che lei è
un ospite e non è un membro a tutti gli
effetti subito la band si trova in giro
per gli stati uniti coinvolta nell'inter
ante spettacolo multimediale di andy
warhol di exploding plastic inevitabile
che è uno spettacolo incredibile
consiste nella proiezione di più film di
warhol contemporaneamente in un uso
esagerato delle luci di scena a
illuminare a giorno tanto è vero che la
bella deve salire sul palco con gli
occhiali da sole per proteggersi le
retine la band che suona un volume
assordante e alcuni attori
dell'entourage di warhol che eseguono
delle danze bizzarre vestiti di pelle
nera e agitando delle fruste e questa è
un'esperienza molto interessante per la
band che li porta appunto in giro per
tutti gli states e poi una volta
rientrati è il momento finalmente di
entrare in studio registrare quest'album
alle già citate canzoni se ne aggiungono
alcune altre che entrano di diritto
nella storia del rock per motivi di
brevità ne citerò solamente al 32
venus in furs è una canzone che parla di
una sordida storia sadomaso sul bordo né
di viola e sunday morning è una ballata
sulla paranoia che aprirà il disco che
purtroppo da noi è più che altro nota
per essere stata usata in uno spot
pubblicitario
quando finalmente quest'albo mesh è un
flop commerciale perché è un flop
commerciale
i motivi sono vari primo tra tutti è un
album troppo innovativo per il proprio
tempo tant'è vero che ad ascoltarlo oggi
a oltre 50 anni della pubblicazione
suona ancora fresco e non da tatto poi
ci sono delle altre problematiche ad
esempio questa copertina sbuccia bile
ideata dai warhol e di difficile
realizzazione e quindi l'uscita viene
posticipata più volte per realizzarla
sul più bello quando finalmente l'album
esce c'è una controversia legale per una
foto sul retro del disco e questo subito
deve essere ritirato dal mercato per
alcuni mesi
e cosa più importante la maggior parte
delle radio considerandolo troppo
estremo si rifiuta di mandarlo in onda
in pochi lo abbiamo acquistato al
momento dell'uscita
ma tutti abbiamo formato una band il
lascito però di quest'album è
importantissimo dal punto di vista
contenutistico lascia alle spalle quello
che era un rock che poteva occuparsi
solo di tematiche leggere e rocca adesso
può occuparsi anche di tematiche adulte
e scabrose e può anche farlo in modo
poetico da un punto di vista musicale
siamo in un momento in cui i chitarristi
stanno migliorando sta per emergere
jimi hendrix sta per emergere dei
progressi della ricerca della tecnica
della perfezione
invece qui abbiamo tre semi incapaci
musicalmente che uniti a un po lo
strumento instabile ma che non sa nulla
di rock che è il genere che andrà a
suonare riescono con la forza delle idee
a creare un capolavoro
quindi una milestone che passa da
un'infanzia difficile culminata con
elettroshock un uomo sessualità repressa
una storia di tossicodipendenza e poi
anche dei fatti positivi invece che sono
l'incontro con un poeta all'incontro con
altri musicisti che hanno la le stesse
vedute e l'incontro con un grande
artista in un'opera che a differenza di
altre che magari hanno un successo
effimero e vengono dimenticate subito
dopo invece continua ad essere
apprezzata e a crescere a più non posso
a distanza di anni e decenni e
sopravvive anche ai propri creatori e
che spero se sono riuscito con questo
speech a incuriosirvi e se gli speaker
che verranno dopo di me non vi faranno
dimenticare tutto quello che ho detto
stasera potrete anche andare a casa
magari ascoltare vi emozionerà grazie
[Applauso]